people
there was a quote from an executive from
a Silicon Valley venture capital firm
early in the pandemic said if they told
us we were going to have to get
everybody to work from home we would
have told management it would take six
months and 10 million dollars when it
actually happened it took three days
with no budget so we all had to adapt to
this new world
and so much more of our lives are online
on our mobile devices and that's all a
huge source of data companies now rely
on that manage their businesses
and they need people who can help them
draw insights from that data so the
amount of data
projected this is an objection from IDC
from a few years ago before the pandemic
uh talking about 175 thatabytes of data
worldwide by 2025
probably the number is actually much
higher now
um and the growth of this industry
I'm going to just
continue to go to a exponential rate
we're looking at uh
tripling over the next several years so
the importance of data and being able to
draw those insights from data is
Paramount for businesses who now look to
find Trends find new ways of addressing
markets by new ways of managing their
manufacturing and Supply chains
affects every aspect of business
education in other organizations
the professor if you'd like to talk a
little bit about some of the data
science roles that people can play
Yeah so basically if you consider the
current scenario the economy Etc and the
fact that this program tries to equip
you well enough with different tools and
techniques so that you can make sense of
the data there are a number of carrier
paths that basically open up for you so
be it a data scientist a data data
analyst architect a machine learning
engineer a statistician
or even an artificial intelligence any
engineer the basis of all these roles is
nothing but data and uh through this
program what we intend to do is to
understand to make you help understand
the importance of data and how do you
actually manage data how do you make
sense of the data what kind of stories
you can tell with the data and this
really helps you in different career
paths irrespective of the industry that
you are working in and this basically
opens up a number of uh different roles
for you
thank you yeah and as you mentioned
Professor it means that you need a
broad range of skills relating to uh
understanding data the algorithms deal
with data the statistical principles
behind those algorithms
um principles of AI and machine learning
all of these things give
you a broad background
that you can draw on and then specialize
in any particular area but um
these are all types of skills that are
covered in the spj IMR program
did you want to make a comment on any of
this
professor I think it's good to go okay
so I'm gonna as I mentioned uh I have a
couple of polls for the audience
during this presentation I'm going to
run the first one right now
and this pretty simple question what are
the things that have kept you from
pursuing a program like this in the past
if you you're interested in becoming a
data science practitioner
um what's kept you from enrolling a data
science education program of this type
so we have these four different
reasons and you can pick one two three
or all four
if you happen to be on a streaming
service you can put ABCD into the
chat box or comment box for your
streaming service
and we'll just keep this open for
another 10 seconds
closing the poll here
so the poll result says that pretty even
distribution of all the different uh
reasons
um mainly people have said that they
don't feel that a program would give
them a practical experience they use to
to apply in their jobs or they don't
have the time in their work schedule
do this so
let's talk about this particular program
this particular program
you do end up with a
comprehensive curriculum with an
industry-lined learning path where spj
IMR has designed this program
according to the needs of Industry what
companies and other organizations have
told them that they want
business clients practitioners
to know and understand and be able to
apply in their work programs a sixth
month completely online program we say
that it requires between five and ten
hours a week maybe a bit more there are
online live virtual classes that you'll
be taking
where you'll interact directly with the
instructor and your peers and your your
class cohort
uh there will be integrated labs and
Hands-On projects on that same digital
platform
um and you can schedule your uh work in
between the classes your homework and
your projects at any time because the
platform is available 24 7 to you along
with support and uh
people that you can contact in case you
have doubts or blockers on any technical
question or any issue with the platform
you can reach out for support 24 7.
you can also contact your peers through
the community bulletin board you can
reach out to your instructors by email
so
this is designed so that you can fit it
into whatever schedule or whatever type
of life plan that you've got
and completed in just six months the QR
code there takes you to the uh
program page on our website but we'll
talk about what this is
um
the program is designed
expressly for use of data science to
support business decision making can you
tell us a little bit about that uh what
the motivation by offering this program
was for the for spj IMR professor yeah
sure
so as you correctly mentioned Stuart uh
so basically the idea came from the
industry itself and uh there was a huge
demand for this uh data science skill
set that
is required in a number of jobs and
different roles and uh we sat down with
the industry specialist we figured out
what where is the gap and what are the
skill sets that is required and then we
had designed this program the curriculum
Etc
which basically talks about or you
builds uh builds the skill set in data
science right from the fundamentals uh
taking you through statistics and the
fundamentals and then the use in the
business for statistics and
understanding the data wrangling
techniques how to manage data how to
manage data in a business scenario and
different machine learning Concepts as
well as their applications and the
business how to do how do you take
decisions based on these techniques
these Concepts how do you use this uh in
terms of getting in profit getting in
revenue and how does this these kind of
techniques help you in taking any kind
of decision uh majorly in this uncertain
environment and current scenarios
thank you yeah and um
the
completion of the program
gives you a certificate from spj IMR
that attests the fact that you've
successfully completed the entire
program you've completed the projects
and the integrated Labs that you'd then
have
in your portfolio to take with you
permanently to show off to uh your
current or potential future employers
and demonstrate how you've used these
skills and how proficient you are with
them along the way you can take the
master classes from the spj IMR faculty
and
you also receive membership in the
executive Alumni network spjmr so that
you can do career networking
lifelong with other people who have
taken
courses through spj IMR so this is a
really valuable
set of tools for your career toolkit
Professor can you tell people more about
the Institute
yeah definitely so SP jamr is one of the
leading Business Schools in India and
abroad uh we have been consistently
ranked among the top five business
schools and the best private B School in
India and we offer different kind of
postgraduate diplomas programs uh
management development programs for
executives part-time programs as well as
full-time programs
so we have a permanent Center in Mumbai
which is one of the uh which is located
in one of the Posh areas in Andheri West
and we also have a
satellite Center kind of a place in uh
Delhi uh so we all our programs are aict
accredited and uh recently we have
received the NBA reaccredition and we
are also accredited by acsp which is one
of the top International accreditation
bodies and we consistently are ranked
among top B schools in the world in
Financial Times Qs rankings and other uh
top management reported rankings
foreign
of some of those rankings from different
institutions so
you can see that the programs and The
Institute itself are ranked extremely
highly
um
of which I'm sure you're very proud
Professor yay I'm sorry
um can you talk a little bit about your
colleagues
so involved on the program definitely so
this program uh would be I mean
facilitated by uh few of my colleagues
Professor Aditi professor ashutosh
professor demali and Professor Merlin
are in the information management and
analytics area so their research is
mainly in cloud computing infrastructure
management
and uh 4G 5G Services Etc Telecom
services and so on and while Professor
demalia is the chair of operations and
supply chain department and his area his
area of research mainly deals with
multi-criteria decision making the use
of analytics and that fuzzy logic Etc so
all of the all of my colleagues are
reported uh professors in their uh
specific areas and have considerable
years of experience both industry and
academic to guide you through this
customized program and help you uh in
your career
thank you
so to become eligible for this or to be
eligible to to apply for this program
you do not have to have a technology
background I mean you do not have to
have it prior coding experience
um if you come into the program without
coding experience we will help you with
any fundamental courses as part of the
program to give you the foundation you
need to succeed in the program you do
require a bachelor's degree in any
discipline
it does not have to be a technology
computer science engineering mathematics
statistics any of that it can be in any
discipline
and we do prefer that you have five or
more years of work experience
um so that you understand
what businesses require in terms of the
problems they need to solve
then have some insight from your
experience on what role data can play in
providing those insights and solving
those problems
so with that I want to ask one more full
question along the way
this one is
how many years of experience uh in the
workforce do you have again this is not
work related to data science necessarily
but just work experience in general
so we'll leave this open for another 15
seconds
all right
so a third of our audience has uh more
than five years of experience
about half of the audience has less than
two years of experience so if you would
like to to enter into this program
you'll need to contact us and we'll
evaluate on a case-by-case basis if you
have that less than five years of
experience
to see if uh you're ready for the
program itself but uh
this is
good information for us to be able to
assess who we're speaking with today so
I'm going to talk about how this program
prepares you and the learning
environment mentioned is fully on online
and
you manage your curriculum
the different courses and I'll go into
the curriculum in just a moment
but you have visibility of all the
courses that make up the program
um you have access to the one that
you're currently working on so that you
complete that successfully it gives you
a foundation for going into the next
course and we
do that deliberately to make sure that
you
build up that set of skills in a
stepwise fashion
the live virtual classroom unless you
interact directly with the instructors
they can show you the exercises they're
working on uh
to share the code exercises they're
doing or the data uh
demonstrations they're doing uh share
with you
types of course assignments code samples
access codes any of that information is
available to you through the learning
management system
and you get to interact directly with
them ask the questions
and interact with your peers as well
tests projects labs are all in that same
online learning environment
and curriculum builds up to a Capstone
project which we will talk about in a
few moments
along the way I'd lock a certificates
certificate for each course that you
complete and then finally the overall
program certificate I I showed a moment
ago
once you have completed the full project
a full program and the Capstone project
and the platform includes support tools
for contacting our 24x7s help desk that
can talk to you about both subject
matter as well as a platform itself
and you also have the community chat
which allows you to interact with your
peers ask them for their opinions and
help and your interface to your
professors to let you
uh get questions answered directly from
them so
I mentioned that the program is built in
a step-by-step fashion
beginning with the orientation session
which
gets you settled in on the learning
management system platform and then uh
introduction to data science the
foundational principles of data science
moving on to
data management within business and how
data science applies specifically in a
business context
um data visualization for business
narration the storytelling that the
professor mentioned
what
information what insights do you draw
from the data and how do you communicate
those insights to company Management in
a way that they can understand
um foundations of Statistics that move
up
into more
detailed information or detailed skills
about
understanding how
insights are actually derived from the
data how statistics tells you
what information the data holds for you
and then applying the statistics to
business forecasting and learning which
techniques apply depending on the type
of data that you're looking at and the
underlying patterns that typically show
up in that data uh next to last is the
machine learning
um module which
allows you to apply some of the Advanced
Techniques in data science and
automated machine technology in order to
apply those kinds of
principles to
data science problem solving in business
machine learning is important because
machine learning is how data science
systems now are able to improve the
quality of the insights they provide
simply by being exposed to more data and
deriving more insights with in them
being able to
build up
a knowledge base on their own of what
that data means
last module is data governance in
business
and the data governance and business
talks about the fundamental um
principles laws regulations rules ethics
of using data within the business
environment
uh and along the way again the elective
which is no additional cost and you can
take it your option is the master
classes from the spga IMR faculty as
well
so this is the overall program
along the way you'll
using different tools a couple of them
are Tableau for visualization
the r language which is specifically
designed for
data science problem solving
you'll be using those in the courses and
doing projects with them so that at the
end
these and other tools and platforms
you'll be able to say
this is how I've used them
you'll be able to demonstrate that
and as I mentioned you'll be doing
various projects throughout the course
of the program
um here's a few examples
what we do is you get a domain for
example Financial domain Healthcare
domain
um
Retail Services domain and within that
domain they'll describe a case study or
specific problem
this is what your if you're working for
a banking institution as an employer
consultant
this is the problem they want solved how
would you use the data science tools to
solve it
may be specific to the particular module
you're in or it may be the Capstone
level
integrating skills you've learned
throughout all the modules of the
program
so
um
Professor Patrick did you want to
mention something about how these
projects are
taken from industry in
selected for this program
yeah so there are these are a couple of
illustrative cases and uh as we as you
can get enrolled in the program you will
see that depending upon your uh uh
industry and background uh curated
project may be given to you which would
help you in making a data driven Edition
in your specialized field so it may
include as it's mentioned here a couple
of illustrative cases as mortgage
analysis or Healthcare prediction uh
data analysis with respect to supply
chain or in terms of marketing new
product development market research
product launches Etc so all these are
actually backed up by data and these are
specific projects that have been curated
only for this program to give you a
Hands-On
understanding of how to use this data in
these kind of scenarios that you would
be facing in your
work industry Etc
thank you
so we talked about the learner profiles
and people coming into this program come
from wide varieties of backgrounds wide
varieties of companies
um
people will be seconded from
their firms to take this course
sometimes
sometimes they take it on their own but
they come out of different sectors not
just the technology sector but as you
can see manufacturing Finance
Consulting pretty much every industry
uses data for business problem solving
and therefore you'll be a cohort that's
pretty broad across Industries
so with that and based on what you've
heard so far
are you interested
in this programming enrolling in this
program
we'll leave that open
again if you're on the streaming
services a b or c into your comments I
do have a in the poll there is a maybe
option so
ABC
yes maybe no
close the poll in five seconds
here is the result
so 94 of our audience oops
put that up on the screen here 94 of our
audience is interested in this program
uh definitely or maybe
and so I will share with you
the steps to enroll very straightforward
uh you email us at simplylearn.net we
are the delivery partner with spjimr for
this program so we manage the learning
platform and also the enrollment process
uh email us at ask us simplylearn.net
and
we will review your application for the
necessary
educational qualifications we'll review
your work background
and
we'll then send you the
offer of admission
and the program schedule the next cohort
uh
should say 16 December I should have
updated that to the later date but the
classes start 7 January 2023 there is an
orientation session but oops sorry
between them now so you haven't missed
it
um
the price of the program is one lock
forty nine thousand which can be
financed with zero percent uh financing
at uh four thousand nine hundred forty
six a month
and
um
for more assistance again you reach out
to us at ask us at simplylearn.net
I'm going to take a moment here to share
in the chat
that
link the email address and the link to
the program page
the
please take a look into the chat
you'll see those available to you
so
um
another quick poll question before we
get to the Q a
if you are interested if you're one of
those 95 percent who said you are
interested now you've seen the schedule
and the um
the cost of the program
uh uh when would you be planning to
start
is this something that you want to do
for that January uh
class cohort is this something look a
little farther out
we'll leave this open for about 15
seconds longer
while we're doing that if you have
questions for Professor batra please put
them into the Q a box that will be much
easier for us to find than in the chat
because there's
often a lot of things coming to us from
the chat
again
almost 70 percent of the audience like
to do this in this coming cohort or the
one right after so
again if you if you're in that category
or if you're in the category looking
further out please do email us at ask us
at simplylearn.net and um
our learning Consultants will
discuss with you your options and keep
you informed about the appropriate time
to join so with that I'm going to
stop sharing the
slide so that we can take your questions
directly
from the Q a
so we have a question from subhajit who
because he's not great in Excel
and that get in the way of using data
science and in business decisions is is
that going to be an issue for him or how
will this program help him overcome that
Professor you have a comment on that I
can also yeah actually anyway I mean
someone from our team has already
responded but uh the idea is that Excel
is not something that we'll be using for
our analysis and it would it won't be an
entrance for you to learn this course
okay uh
uh we're looking at
I think we'll share a response from uh
a question by Canal who asks can you
tell us
which is preferable at Ms and data
science or an MBA and business analytics
and data science and the response
from Twitter from uh spj IMR one of your
colleagues that the
MS program would be more Technical and
MBA more business oriented
um yeah
the durations are usually different this
particular program is a six month fully
online certification program so it
allows you to get a number of the skills
that you want to apply directly
um it's not a masters of science or an
MBA program however
certification program
uh
there's a question about a number of
hours a week for the lectures uh five to
seven hours a week of lectures is
a number
and
there are yes assessments quizzes and a
project in the program so that along the
way for each of the modules I described
in the
curriculum do you have Assessments in
order to be able to successfully pass on
to the next module at the end of the
program
final project that acts as a
overall assessment for your completion
of the program
and question also about online sessions
live or recorded the there are live
classes
of course recordings are made out of
these in case you miss them but there's
an expectation and you should come into
the program expecting to attend the live
classes weekly
um
there you will have access to the
recordings to review what you learned or
in case there's a weekend or session
that you couldn't make the class
um but uh again you want to commit to
being at the live classes as often as
possible there is a
sort of a requirement for a minimum
number that you have to be at live
um
placement assistance so uh
this is not a placement course
uh you'd want to contact us and ask us
at simplylearn.net in order to um
learn more about
what
career assist Services might be
available to you
um
class timings we had a question from
uh vipin who asks about class timings
they are Saturday evenings six to nine
PM Indian time
and
a question from uh
user UI dreams I guess if I'm reading
that correctly what do I do to become a
data scientist
that's a great question I can talk a
little bit about that maybe Professor
Patrick you can address that as well
this program is not going to qualify you
as a data scientist
per se
it qualifies you as a practitioner of
data science
or solving business problems
um
data scientists usually uh
require more in-depth
understanding of
the principles algorithms
mathematics behind data science in order
to be able to develop
new algorithms
new methods or models and in an
organization usually the data scientist
would be assigned to look at
data problem and come up with Which
models to apply design new models or
algorithms if those are necessary and
then data science
practitioners analysts and that type of
thing would apply those to specific
problems on an ongoing basis but
um Professor did you want to comment on
that difference from your perspective
no no fair enough I think and as we said
that
this is a
the codes cannot make you a data
scientist just basically introduces you
to the data how to deal with the data
how to make effective business decisions
using different tools and techniques
that we learn in this course and this
program so it points you towards the
right direction and uh helps you in
making a career in data science but uh
rest it's up to you to pick it up from
there
and uh Canal asks about statistics of
edited the Career Success after the
program this is a new program so we
don't have that historical information
for you but you can contact us at ask us
at simplylearn.net
and share with you some information
about how
people have fared from similar
programs in the past
um
and you can use that as comparative data
you can also look on any of the job
boards
looking for you know what data analysts
and data scientists are paid you would
look at the data analyst category or
business analyst category
uh more of a as a baseline for this
program and you can see what what
prevailing South uh salaries are
available there
um
and I think
Professor have you seen any uh other
questions that you wanted to
specifically address
no I don't think so I think more or less
we have addressed everything
okay
um we have just one last question here
from Hari Krishnan who completed an MCA
in 2017.
um
has not been working as a software
professional professional if I
understand the question correctly but is
uh interested in this data science
course
um
is it likely to qualify him for
employment so uh
har Krishna and the the the
nature of this course is to give you
skills that you can demonstrate through
the portfolio project that you end up
with and to um able to show that off
to potential employers
um and this is not a placement program
so there's no job guarantee involved
with it however
um
our experience at simply learned with
similar programs is that
graduates have a good success rate
getting employment at
good salary packages so
um again not a guarantee but we think
this is a great program for people who
want to move into the data science
business field
then I'm going to conclude the question
and answer period
move on to the last question for the
audience
excuse me
Please share my screen
you'll have that one last question here
so
um
just a quick question for people who are
interested in the program especially
those who want to join that
next cohort in January
uh do you require assistance from us
leave this open for about
20 seconds I don't think it needs to be
open the full 30.
and
yeah we have one or two people answering
so just under half the audience would
like assistance from us in getting
enrolled so
again for that
you contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net again I will put that
information into the chat before we
conclude
and
we want to thank Professor Patra for
being here today
and helping us with this presentation
sharing with us generously from your
your knowledge and experience Professor
thank you
and we also want to thank everyone else
here
all of you in the audience who joined us
today both on our streaming audiences
and here on LinkedIn or WebEx rather
um
again in the chat is that uh email
address and the link to the
program page you can also scan the QR
code
get to our program page
with that
we've concluded the webinar so
one last thank you to all you for um
joining today
and we look forward to welcoming you
into the learning computer Community
with spjimr
have a great rest of your evening